un accord plutôt favorable aux
créanciers est ce que c'est un avis que
vous partagez marielle de sarnez vice
présidente du mouvement démocrate et
sous réserve d'inventaire il faudra voir
maintenant comment les choses se font
comment elle se précise je trouve que
oui c'est favorable aux créanciers bon
c'est un peu normal c'est eux qui
prêtent l'argent va dire qu'ils mettent
l'argent soit à mais en même temps en
même temps je trouve qu'il y a dans ce
plan des choses qu'il n'y avait pas dans
les plans précédents
il ya d'abord l'obligation et c'est très
important de conduire un certain nombre
de réformes structurelles en grèce
ça c'est absolument important comme ça
on le savait avant lui s'y connaît même
de la semaine dernière on savait il
fallait qu'on le sait et ça peut
réformer la grèce ça ne se fait pas et
d'ailleurs faut quand même donner vous
pensez que ça l'ait quoi anticipera ce
sera hélas que depuis cinq mois et qu'il
n'est pas responsable de la situation de
la grèce détériorée depuis 40 ans donc
il a à faire maintenant le boulot que
ses prédécesseurs
aucun d'entre eux de droite ou de gauche
socialiste ou conservateurs n'ont fait
donc ça c'est le premier point il va y
avoir des réformes structurelles
il faudra qu'on soit aux côtés de type
race aux côtés des grecs pour les aider
et les accompagner dans ses réformes
structurelles
deuxième chose j'espère qu'il va y avoir
une partie de cet argent et c'était
toute la question du fonds de
privatisation qui va être consacré à
l'investissement parce que c'est
extrêmement important de donner des
perspectives
on peut avoir des mesures comptables et
donc financières mais il faut qu'on ait
des mesures économiques et c'est ça qui
lie à peut-être dans ce plan sous
réserve d'inventaire comme je vous le
disais et enfin troisièmement troisième
chapitre de ce plan un rééchelonnement
de la dette pour permettre justement
d'essayer de réamorcer réamorcer amorcer
le développement de la grèce c'est ça
les questions qui sont aussi celles de
sarnez je vous ai vu beaucoup réagir
pendant l'interview de jacques il parle
de retour à la case départ de diktat
allemand est ce que c'est à dire que je
partage une signature c'est pour que les
choses ne marchent pas et donc moi c'est
pas du tout l'état d'esprit qui à
prévalu cette nuit et c'est pas mon état
d'esprit est ce qu'on a tous envie que
l'europe s'en sorte que la grèce s'en
sortent
la réponse est oui alors après ce que
c'est que c'est facile non c'est pas
facile
si c'était facile on n'aurait pas eu
besoin de tous ses sauts mais de tous
ces plans depuis cinq années
donc oui on a un problème et ce qu'il
faut y faire face ensemble oui il faut y
faire face ensemble
alors on a des courants politiques en
france on voit bien il ya des
sensibilités politiques qui sont du côté
des eurosceptiques qui aurait aimé que
tout ça éclate que la zone euro éclate
qu'elle se délite qu'elle se défasse que
les grecs sortent aujourd'hui de la zone
euro demain ça aurait été peut-être le
portugal et puis l'italie paie peut-être
pourquoi pas un jour la france puisque
c'est au four ce qu'ils veulent qui est
de zone à la zone des pays forts un
l'euro fort
et puis le club med entre guinée bah
écoutez moi c'est pas du tout mon point
de vue ce courant il existe en france
malheureusement ce que je vois là moi
c'est que l'europe elle a résisté
l'europe elle a décidé de rester unis
vous vous rendez compte sur n'avait pas
été capable d'essayer d'apporter des
réponses aux difficultés que traverse la
grèce aujourd'hui ensemble comment
voulez vous qu'on soit capable demain
d'apporter des réponses à tous les
enjeux qui sont mes monstrueux
l'enjeu de dèche l'enjeu du terrorisme
l'enjeu de des migrations qui sont des
questions très importantes pour l'europe
il fallait régler cette question de la
grèce c'était très important pour
marielle de sarnez une réaction sur
l'attitude d'alexis tsipras ce il y a
une semaine il y a quelques jours et
c'est vrai que je peux reconnaître que
c'est compliqué à suivre depuis cinq
mois et que lui-même peut-être a pris du
temps quand il est venu au parlement
européen d'ailleurs il nous a dit c'est
cinq mois je les ai davantage passées à
négocier qu'à gouverner sas everest dont
tacle au fond moi il ya une lucidité
chez lui qui apparaît ensuite ce
référendum grec c'est plus compliqué que
ça en a l'air à la vérité il ya un grec
qui a dit cette phrase qui est une
phrase allah raffarin dans le nom il y
avait du oui et dans le oui avait du nom
ainsi on dirait du raffarin mais il ya
quelque chose d'assez juste l'éclat
qu'ils avaient envie d'exprimer une
forme de come ca de ras-le-bol ça
faisait des années qu'ils avaient ce
référendum rentrée qu'on leur avait au
fond interdit d'organiser il ya quelques
années et en même temps ils ont toujours
voulu rester dans la zone euro c'est à
dire qu'il voulait dire non et en même
temps il voulait un accord il voulait un
deal est ce qui aurait été le plus
inquiétant pour les grecs c'est qu'il
n'y ait pas d'accord et on avait donc
cette double attente ou cette double
expression des grecs
alors c'est peut-être quelquefois les
peuples ont des complexités mais il faut
aussi les prendre
content guard le feuilleton n'est pas
fini de sarnez mais est ce que vous
estimez quand même que finalement la
crise a plutôt été bien gérée par
françois hollande et que finalement le
couple franco-allemand a résisté
je trouve que là de nouveau à cette
crise rend sa tenue sa place honnêtement
ce serait difficile de dire le contraire
le couple franco-allemand a résisté bien
que deux cultures différentes de
position politiques différentes
ils ont géré ensemble cette nuit et
c'est tant mieux
donald tusk que je trouve à bien
présider en tous les cas il a participé
de l'accouchement de cet accord dont
nous verrons dans les semaines et les
mois qui viennent s'il est durable et je
souhaite qu'il le soit jean claude
juncker a joué également sa partie mais
je voudrais dire un mot si vous me le
permettez je pense qu'il ya maintenant
une double exigence qui est devant nous
on a une exigence
évidemment les grecs il faut une
exigence vis-à-vis de la grèce et du
gouvernement grec
il faut que les réformes structurelles
soient conduites il faut qu'elle soit
menée tout en donnant apte à ty braz qui
n'est là que depuis cinq mois mais
maintenant et c'est le temps pour faire
et pour lancer ces réformes
structurelles il faudra que l'europe
soit aux côtés du gouvernement grec pour
l'aider à faire les réformes
structurelles
il faudra de l'investissement pour
recréer de la croissance travailler sur
je ne sais pas le solaire l'éolien se
dotait d'une agriculture bref toutes
choses dont aujourd'hui la grèce enfin
quand je dis aujourd'hui ça fait
quarante années n'a plus et donc je
trouve que rennes tenait le plan en
échange de tout cela c'est une bonne
chose et une double exigence parce qu'
il faudra aussi une exigence pour le
cercle de l'euro il va falloir que le
cercle de l'euro face en fin continue à
faire de la politique et de l'économie
que ça soit pas seulement les ministres
des finances qui se réunissent mais que
ce soit aussi les ministres de
l'économie qu'on fasse converger qu'on
avance vers plus de politique
hébert plus d'économique dans la zone
euro merci à vous tous